you ready samantha had always wanted a
big fan
two maybe three children but as for many
mothers the decision
isn't that simple when we were
considering
you know we'd love to have another child
but
would i have time would i have that
support there
i don't think so and that's one of the
hardest things and it's a it's a hard
pill to swallow really
the infrastructure's not there to
support a mother in work
and at home right now do you think you
could afford to have children
no with the cost of child care i don't
understand how anyone
can afford to have a life have a child
extrapolate these millions of
conversations across the country and
perhaps they help explain
a striking trend the number of children
being had by the average woman the total
fertility rate
is falling if the fertility rate is
below 2.1 the replacement rate the white
line here
that means that in the absence of
migrants the population will fall
according to the latest data the rate
dropped late last year
to 1.6 children per woman that's the
lowest level since comparable records
began
it is part of the explanation for why
the uk population
is thought to have fallen last year
according to one estimate it dropped by
as much as a million
falling fertility rates though are only
one part of the story there's higher
deaths from covet and more than anything
else
an almost unprecedented exodus of
migrant workers
so it looks as if 2020 was the
first year since world war ii that we
saw a really significant population fall
across the uk
um and it's ironic that this is coming
just as we're coming up to the 10 yearly
census
at a time when because of the pandemic
of course there's lots of uncertainty
when we may have seen a very large
outflow
of people going back um to the countries
where they first come
came from adlin is another person
thinking of doing just that
she's lived here for more than half a
decade but is now thinking of returning
to france
this last year with the kovid
and everything we i couldn't see my
family
especially then we have to quarantine
and i can't as i'm working and i can't
work from home
so it was very hard for me we've got
also a chat
together in london all of our life
is based in london so it's a it's it's a
big decision
some would say the country is already
overpopulated and that this is no bad
thing
but with falling house prices and empty
homes in london there's already an
economic impact
one of the big conundrums of the past
year has been why the uk economy has
been so badly affected
by covert worse than almost any other
country in the world now
it could be down to the fact that the
lock down was harsher it could be
measurement
issues but what if it is population
because if hundreds of thousands of
people are moving out
not coming back and that means hundreds
of thousands of jobs that aren't taking
place
in short it could affect everything
decade after decade census after census
this country has built
its economy on a rising population
rising tax revenues rising nhs spending
rising incomes they're all predicated on
more people living here
if this isn't a blip if the country is
emptying out permanently
then all the old economic equations
about how we finance our standards of
living
are out of the window ed conway sky news